for each of these diagrams I want to
think about whether this blue line
represents an axis of symmetry and the
way we can tell is if on both sides of
the blue line we essentially have mirror
images so let's imagine let's take this
top this top part of this polygon the
part that is above this blue line here
and let's reflect it across the blue
line you could almost imagine that it's
a reflection over some type of a lake or
something and see if we get exactly what
we have below then this would be an axis
of symmetry so this point right over
here this distance to the blue line
let's go the same amount on the other
side would get you right there and so
you immediately see we start ending up
with a point that is off off what's
actually here in black the actual bottom
part of the polygon so this is a pretty
good clue that this is not an axis of
symmetry but let's just continue it just
to just to go through the exercise so
this point if you're reflected it across
this blue line would get you here this
point would in a different color this
point if you were to reflect it across
this blue line it would get you make
sure I could do that it relatively
straight I can do a straighter job than
that so if you go about that distance
about it and I'm going to go straight
down into the blue line and say I'm
gonna go the same distance on the other
side it gets me to right around there
and then this point over here if I were
to drop it straight down straight down
then if I were to go the same distance
on the other side it gets me right
around there and then finally this point
gets me right around there so it's
mirror image of this top part would look
something like this would look something
something like something like this my
best attempt to draw it would look
something like this which is very
different than the part of the polygon
that's actually on the other side of
this blue line so in this case the blue
line is not an axis of symmetry so this
is no no this blue line is not an axis
of symmetry now let's look at over here
and our eyes pick this out very
naturally here you can see that it looks
like this blue line really divides this
polygon in half it really does look like
mirror images it really does look like
if you imagine that the
is some type of a this is some type of a
lake that still lake so I shouldn't
actually draw waves but this is some
type of a lake that this is the
reflection and we can even go point by
point here
so this point right over here is the
same distance from if we dropped a
perpendicular to this point as this one
right over here this one over here same
distance same distance as this point
right over here and we could do that for
all of the points so in this case the
blue line does represent an axis of
symmetry